[Music]
you probably won't know their faces
but they want you to know their stories
these are the boys who dreamed of being
premier league footballers
some still do at any given time there
are around 12
000 boys in football's youth development
system
they all dream of playing football for a
living for some
it presents an enticing route out of
poverty
but fewer than one percent will ever
make it into the professional ranks
i want to find out what happens to the
hundreds of footballers who are released
into obscurity each year
i travel around the uk to investigate
whether these children are adequately
prepared for life and alternative
careers
and if the culture inside academies
contributes to the feeling of desolation
outside the boy broken
physically and mentally the boy who
became a class a drug dealer
the boy so depressed his mum put him on
suicide watch
the boy who lost his dad and briefly his
love for the game
and the boy who is bravely speaking out
even though he's still playing high
level football
[Music]
jeremy whiston shared the dream the 18
year old was found hanged in his bedroom
last october
he was his parents say devastated after
being released from manchester city
academy
a full inquest will be held in the
spring the club has been asked to
provide a statement
detailing support that was given to him
following his release
jeremy's death has prompted soul
searching in football
counselling has been stepped up in
academies and many wonder if
more could have been done
[Music]
my first stop is bristol where i meet
tom who was at bristol city academy from
the age of 12 to 19 when he was released
he only realized the full extent of the
trauma when he broke down several years
later
i can actually remember sitting in the
room with the therapist for the first
time and
we were talking about my injury and what
would happen in my story
and i just remember i just started
crying and i was like
where did that come from right and you
start to dig in and actually
i realized number one i i just didn't
know myself
my whole identity was built around being
a footballer it's like that's why i was
in my eyes why i was popular why people
liked me it was who i was
now at 31 tom's release from bristol
academy
signaled a downward spiral into crime i
wasn't
obviously earning a lot of money and i
was like where can i find
money from and and status and lifestyle
that is similar
to being a footballer which is 18 19
years old was like
part of what i kind of liked about it
was was this
and the areas that i used to hang around
in
and some people that i knew i knew who
were making good money selling drugs and
to me i was like wow oh i could do that
he spent eight months in a youth
offenders institute after police caught
him with cocaine
i was a son to be proud of her playing
for bristol city and
you know they're they're proud of me and
now i've brought
shame if you like to to the family tom
checked into the sporting chance clinic
for sportsmen and women with addiction
problems
i was completely lost completely lost
and just didn't understand really what
had happened to me and part of that is
obviously being young and
and stuff but also having no one ever
tell me about any of this stuff or
support me
around this stuff which i look back now
and just think is
crazy that there isn't something there
to to help with that
next up i visit south east london a
hotbed of footballing talent
many from deprived communities who see
the game as an escape for themselves
and their families kofi who grew up on a
council estate in peckham is one of them
as a kid he played alongside arsenal's
reece nelson and jaden sancho
now one of europe's best young players
he was scouted to play for two different
academies
at 14 he lost his dad to cancer and
struggled with what he says is the harsh
environment of football
i expect you to grow up man up that
typical man
up like especially on the pitch when you
get fouled man up it's not that
difficult it's not that bad but for some
of us
a lot of us sometimes it's not just a
man-up thing sometimes it's a thing of
i'm going through something here and i
need some help do you feel like
football kind of exploits those dreams
particularly of those kids i've come to
understand that football's a business
especially from where i've come from is
literally the only escape but
if your your father passes and it's just
you and your mum
older siblings but they obviously get on
their life the only thing that makes you
happy is playing football because it's
just an innocent dream at the end of the
day you just want to play in the premier
league kofi still hopes to get his
football career back on track
but when he was released by barnet he
flirted with gang life
[Music]
ces works with young players in south
london and says many released can be
tempted to go that way
young people got to do what's easiest
they're always going to do what's
easiest
and if it's easier to go onto the street
and do something illegal to make money
they're going to do that because they
used to feel in a certain way they used
to be in that person who's
oh the center of attention oh you're at
academy oh you're going to do this
you're going to do that
so when that attention goes you're going
to want attention in different ways
that's human nature so what we're not
doing is actually getting to the crux of
the issue and saying right
this comes down to the emotional
regulation of young people the emotional
intelligence but also
understanding the opportunities and lack
of opportunities that these young people
have
and if we don't understand that then
we're never going to understand the
problem
[Music]
max is 10 years older than kofi he was
one of the country's best young talents
playing for fulham and representing
wales at youth level
football academy is a really toxic
environment they're young boys who are
coached and looked after by men who
don't care for them and i think that's
the biggest issue that there's no care
in football
and so at 16 i'm getting injections in
my knees
at 16 years old getting painkillers
given to me daily um i've got stories of
my friends who would go out with four or
five strappings on their legs just to
train
so you're playing through pain you're
playing through all of these niggles is
what we call them in football but
they're not legal
because later down the line they're
gonna they're gonna have a serious
problem and that's that's what happened
to me
since doing this interview with sky news
earlier this month
max says he's been contacted by 30 to 40
other boys with similar stories
[Music]
he takes me to meet one of them ashley
who he played with at fulham academy
and ashley's mum linda he was released
at 19 after suffering a groin injury
doctors he's seen since then say the
injury wasn't rehabbed properly
but i went home and i waited for the
football club to contact me and help me
and that the help didn't come
by the time i was able to look into it
myself
and try to forge out something for
myself it was too late a lot of football
clubs
weren't taking on players anymore and
that sent me into a wild depression
i honestly don't know how we got through
it um
i'm sorry
i found myself every single day before i
went to work
going into my son's room to check he was
breathing
i was taking days off work because i was
absolutely convinced that that was the
day he was going to take his life
i couldn't recognize who he was and
there was nothing
i could do to help him absolutely
nothing
i'm a qualified counsellor and i could
do nothing to help my son
i realized very quickly that i'm no
longer in this
in this world in this industry of being
a footballer i'm in a completely
different world a world where
i don't know how to have a seat make a
cv i don't know how to apply for jobs um
i don't know how to how to do anything
along those lines
apart from play football let's call it
what it is it's abuse and
nobody should have that kind of power
over anybody let alone adults over
children
my son was sold a dream
i was sold the same dream i had little
to no experience
of the footballing world under those
circumstances were any of these boys
told
that you know the the likelihood of them
making it is
meninsula they were going to make it
fulham say they're investigating both
max and ashley's claims
but today have found nothing to support
them the clubs say they've reached out
on numerous occasions to the former
players concerned
but are yet to receive a response
i've been invited to charlton academy
which has a rich heritage of bringing
through youngsters
to see what they've put in place to help
avoid their released players feeling
like ashley
10 years later here they pride
themselves on their education programme
even running regular player care
sessions focusing on preparing their
players to cope in the event
that football doesn't become a future
career
there's always going to be
some sort of emotional fallout when a
player leaves a club
it's inevitable especially if you've got
a boy that's been with you for so long
some of these lads that i've known i've
known since they were eight nine years
of age
which is why it's absolutely incumbent
upon us again
to make sure that we engage with that um
that mental
emotional well-being personal
development piece
when we can when they're here there's
around 180 youngsters registered in
charlton's academy
but under the premier league rules of
developments other clubs could have up
to 250 children and young people
registered in their academies given the
minuscule numbers that actually make it
to the professional ranks
it's led some to suggest that this is a
form of mind sweeping
with children the collateral damage i
ask the education director at the
professional footballers association
if academies are taking in too many
players these lads want the opportunity
to become professional footballers
and if you suddenly took that
opportunity away from them
the industry could leave itself wide
open then to be
uh criticized for for not offering those
opportunities
to these young players
[Music]
i make my way to south wales to meet an
18 year old who is
by the narrow definition of football
academy life
making it ali plays for swansea under
23s and is on the fringes of the first
team
the dream is tantalisingly close
it's rare to hear a youngster in the
system deliver a critical analysis
but ali's moral fiber runs deep
particularly when it comes to jeremy
whiston
the 18 year old released from manchester
city academy
found hanged in his bedroom last october
he was actually on trial at swansea a
few months before that so i'd obviously
seen him and spoke to the lad and
obviously i wasn't close to them or
anything but a few of the other boys
were quite close to him and knew him
and so on the day i found out what that
was i get goosebumps now just talking
about they were just
just stretching on the on the mat and
then you look at your phone and see
somebody's took their own life
and straight away you can relate to that
in the weirdest way possible because
that might sound
it's not a suicidal way but you can
relate to them feelings that that person
has gone through because you've been
through them as well
so you can relate to that loneliness you
can relate to that stress and the
anxiety and that worry and that
obviously some people's a lot more
amplified than others
and but yeah it's just it's crazy how it
gets that point
ali like many i speak to talks of a
toxic masculinity in football academies
there is only one female coach working
in a premier league youth system
it's also the pressure of unrelenting
scrutiny
and the toll it takes on young minds if
you're going through your whole academy
system
constantly trying to impress if you've
been judged you've been trying to
impress and press and press and press
until you get to a certain point and you
know you're not good enough
what what's what's the next step and and
again that's why maybe draw some of
these people to do
some of some of the things that we've
heard about over the last few weeks it
needs to be a change then more of a
change in environment and culture
when say a board of directors or
whatever executives come into a room
all they're trying to do is make sure
they're taking all these boxes you know
have we got a welfare officer
are we doing this twice a week are we
doing that three times a week then that
needs to go on to maybe another meeting
where
are we doing this for the right reasons
you know are we actually doing this
because we want to help these players
and want to help
help them fail their career after us or
are we doing it because
because we just have to do it um because
at the end of the day we are products
unfortunately and it is a business so
if you're not needed they're just going
to pass you on or sell you
[Music]
education welfare and mental health
support has improved drastically in
football academies
but the game takes in and spits out
hundreds of kids each year
starting at nine years old a tiny
percentage will ever make any money from
the game
it's arithmetic which only makes sense
for the multi-billion pound business
of football